[Musique]
pourquoi garder sa vieille voiture
pollue moins que d'acheter une neuve en
suisse et dans les pays occidentaux
l'écologie est régulièrement réduite à
une question d'affaires de dépenses
d'énergie on parle beaucoup d'énergie
fossile d'énergies renouvelables ce qui
veut dire que nos programmes politiques
nationaux s'accorde surtout sur ce qui
sort des poids légèrement de voitures ce
qui sort des cheminées nos maisons et
sur le nucléaire depuis fukushima
c'est ce que j'appelle la première
notion qui est l'énergie consommée dans
le pays donc les rejets co2 dans le pays
à partir de là nous en tant que citoyens
nous sommes régulièrement invité à
changer d'objets pour économiser de
l'énergie
changer de voiture pour consommer moins
d'essence
changez d'électroménager pour continuer
à consommer moins d'électricité
mais au final est ce vraiment une bonne
solution ou une bonne idée premier
constat développer cette vision c'est
faire fi d'une deuxième dimension
deuxième dimension qui est l'énergie
grise l'énergie grise
c'est l'un des plus grands vecteurs de
pollution et pourtant nos programmes
politiques ne viennent pas du tout
content et ça c'est grave
l'énergie grise c'est toute l'énergie
que nous êtres humains avons besoin pour
fabriquer un objet que ce soit parce
qu'à chaque fois que nous fabriquons
objet chaque fois nous avons besoin d'
usine pour le faire et six usines seront
fortement axée sur les énergies fossiles
donc renaître en masse du co2 dans
l'atmosphère l'énergie grise
on la retrouve aussi lorsque l'on
fabrique un pont un tunnel une route une
maison à trous mais matri impôts lui
passe pour faire un trou on a besoin de
pelles mécaniques de peine
cani qui sont elles-mêmes bourré
d'énergie crise parce qu'il a fallu est
fabriqué le nahd le camion de camions
qui ont eux-mêmes bout riedinger crise
parce qu'elle est fabriquée et surtout
aussi bien la pelle mécanique que le
camion on voudrait de pétrole pour
fonctionner une fois qu'on a fabriqué
nos objets et nos routes
alors après on a toute une panoplie
d'objets roulants qu'on appelle camions
voitures qui vont transporter ces objets
sur ces routes des objets roulants qui
eux mêmes sont bourrés d'énergie grise
parce qu a fallu les fabriquer et des
objets roulants qui ont besoin de
pétrole pour fonctionner l'énergie grise
la deuxième dimension c'est l'énergie
consommée dans le monde pour fabriquer
tous les objets qui nous entourent au
quotidien alors changé d'appareil pour
économiser de l'énergie
est ce une bonne idée nous écobilan nous
le disent eux qui calcule d'énergie
grise mais attention ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'un écobilan c'est une
estimation est plus un objet est
complexe plus l'estimation est
approximative voire grossière d'où la
question est ce que ces chiffres
approximatifs peut vraiment nous donner
la bonne direction à suivre
prenons un objet complexe la voiture
combien de pièces dans une voiture
combien de pièces et bien une voiture
c'est en moyenne 180 milles composants
mais attention ce sont collés
qu'opposant pour avoir le nombre de
pièces
il s'agit de faire x 2 x 4 selon le
composant donc une voiture ce sont des
centaines de milliers de pièces
imaginées
imaginez le nombre de kilomètres
parcourus ces pièces à travers le monde
pour être réunis en un seul endroit en
ce lieu pour constituer la voiture
imaginée dès lors le nombre de
kilomètres qu'une voiture a déjà
parcouru avant même d'être voiture c'est
phénoménal
une voiture c'est en moyenne plus de
deux kilomètres de câbles électriques
prochaine fois fois vous allez vous
promenez vous faite une marche de 2 km
imaginez vous que la distance que vous
avez parcouru équivaut à la longueur des
câbles que vous avez dans votre voiture
phénoménal on comprend avec un écobilan
pas facile d'avoir des chiffres qui soit
vraiment précis tout à fait normal ces
estimations mais est ce que ces
estimations ce fils suffisante pour nous
éclairer sur la bonne voie à suivre
bon admettons mais moi je te propose de
transcender nous écobilan pour découvrir
une troisième dimension troisième
dimension qui est la pollution chimique
ce qui est important de savoir c'est que
lorsque nous êtres humains nous
fabriquons un objet au delà de l'énergie
grise
nous avons aussi besoin de filière
chimique de la chimie qui durant le
processus de fabrication
indubitablement fini dans l'eau dans les
sols et dans les airs et plus un objet
est complexe plus la filière chimique
est imposante
imaginez vous pour une voiture la trois
dimensions ce sont donc les rejets de
substances toxiques dans le monde pour
fabriquer tous les objets qui nous
entourent au quotidien et plus va
beaucoup d'objets plus nous rejetons de
la chimie et des rejets de substances
toxiques dans l'eau dans les sols et
dans les airs on peut pas faire
autrement c'est un état de fait ce n'est
pas une idéologie ce n'est pas un
opinion ce n'est pas une vue de l'esprit
c'est un fait c'est c'est ainsi à ce
stade on comprend que chaque fois que
nous êtres humains nous fabriquons objet
à chaque fois nous bergeron la vie
quelque part sur terre et plus le
fabricant d'objets plus nous pèserons la
ville quelque part sur terre
pour illustrer ses propos je vous
propose de partir voyage est de sortie
me franck rlv tic pouvoir qu'est ce que
ça veut dire de fabrique un objet
première étape déforestation pour
atteindre la matière première dont on a
besoin pour continuer constitue l'objet
on va commencer par éradiquer la vie à
la surface de la terre
éradiquer la vie végétale éradiquer la
vie animale et toute la microbiologie
des sols
une fois que cette première étape
d'éradication d'éradication de la vie à
sauver la terre
on peut passer à l'extraction et
l'extraction
vous allez voir les trous sont grands
sont énormes et fenêtres ou énorme
on a besoin de machine énorme voilà une
foreuse à charbon voyez au pied cette
machine vous avez des voitures imaginez
lorsque l'auteur cette machine c'est
phénoménal
c'est 95 m de hauteur 2 121 m de long
hu imaginez vous la quantité d'énergie
grise qui était nécessaire pour
fabriquer un agenda c'est aussi grande
celui là imaginez vous la déforestation
et la présence chimiques et nsr faille
tirer l'acier de la terre énorme
à votre gauche vous avez un tract au
dessus des tracks voulait une roue c'est
roues d'acier c'est ce qui va creuser la
terre se trouve là si elle fait 21
mètres de hauteur
ça équivaut un immeuble de sept étages
or images niveau la force qu'il faut
pour mettre en roulant en mouvement une
roues d'acier équivalent un immeuble de
sept étages mais non seulement la mettra
en route et la sphère en mouvement mais
en plus croquant cru et sol s'est
énormément d'énergie
un trou ça pollue ça pollue énormément
prochaine fois que vous rencontrez un
trou pensez-y
on va voir cette machine et ses copines
travailler ici dans une mine de charbon
en allemagne à hambach là vous pouvez
compter six machines de ce type là où
elle paraît tout petit parce que c'est
tellement grand chryso l'es18 et vous
pouvez voir que il ya cinq machines
superposent excuses de ce trophée au
minimum 500 mètres de profondeur
mais il ya mieux aux etats unis cette
mine de cuivre là au delà de la
superficie qui est énorme quant aux
éléments les montagnes son travail à qui
son père c'est à la perpendiculaire
c'est aussi la profondeur du trou que ce
trou l'a fait 1200 mètres de profondeur
un kilomètre de sens profond de roi
imaginez abyssal wa pourquoi aussi
profond pas utiliser de plus en plus de
cuivre
la nouvelle technologie nos ordinateurs
nos téléphones portables
notez-bien écran plat nos voitures nos
robots l'intelligence artificielle save
the cuivres
donc on creuse de plus en plus profond
une fois qu'on a atteint 6 matières
premières va passer à la fabrication et
là on va voir que les usines qui sont
utilisés pour fabriquer des objets mais
ça change un peu des usines que nous
avons l'habitude de croiser dans notre
quotidien
voici par exemple une centrale à charbon
du côté de l'allemagne où une raffinerie
de pétrole du côté des états unis ou
encore une aciérie en chine tout objet
métallique pas obligatoire
obligatoirement par là on se rend compte
qu'à 13 petit échantillon d'industrie
lourde pas facile de fabriquer un objet
s'arrête en masse et pas que les co2
alors changé d'objet pour économiser
l'énergie
est ce une bonne idée pas sûr à force
nous sommes arrivés à une gestion
incontrôlable des déchets nous
fabriquons tellement nous générons
tellement déchets que nous avons inventé
des cimetières d'un nouveau genre des
cimetières elop ne les cimetières de
voitures ou des cimetières d'avions
on peut se rendre compte que dans les
fêtes la quantité devient le problème
aujourd'hui nous avons un problème de
quantité
et cela s'explique car pour part
ivre à baisser notre consommation
d'énergie nous sommes régulièrement
invité à augmenter votre consommation
matérielle
alors il ya le recyclage le recyclage
c'est bien le recyclage c'est propre
c'est le futur c'est la solution doit y
est voici une usine de recyclage en
suisse un même groupe que le recyclage
c'est bourré d'énergie grise le
recyclage c'est pas propre du tout mais
surtout au moment où le site s'est trop
tard les grands dégâts environnementaux
ont déjà eu lieu
il s'agit de se mettre beaucoup plus en
amont c'était la fabrication que les
grands dégâts environnementaux ont lieu
alors si je dis c'est attention il faut
que je précise bien peu propos là ce que
je vous dis je vous dis ça c'est pour
que l'on se nettoie d'esprit que le
recyclage ses propres essais pour qu'on
se nettoie d'esprit que le recyclage
c'est la solution
j'entends trop souvent des personnes de
bonne conscience qu'ils disent oui j'ai
changé mais c'est bon c'est recyclé tu
parles c'est pas bon du tout il s'agit
de positionner beaucoup d'un amour c'est
pas parce qu'on recycle qu'on peut se
permettre de continuer à produire autant
que ce compromis aujourd'hui et la
voiture en la voiture nous dit qu'une
voiture c'est 95% la voiture est recyclé
attention on parle du poids c'est 90 %
du poids de la voiture
tous les composants synthétiques passe à
la décharge il ya une décharge de ce
type là nonant le pin en france qui
entre en problème parce que la rivière
qui passe en dessous des charges est
pollué une voiture c'est pas tout
regardé en 2016
cent trente mille voitures exporter de
suisse cent trente mille voitures pour
un petit pays de huit millions
d'habitants
imaginez vous les pays voisins qui nous
entoure des voitures qui partent pour
l'afrique ou perlée pour les pays d'est
alors charger sa voiture pour économies
d'énergie en fait s'il continue à rouler
dans notre pays franchement on n'a pas
gagné sur le plan global
on est tous sur la même planète et puis
pire on va même accéléré le problème
du fait que six voitures vous roulez
dans des pays qui ne sont pas organisés
comme et l'autre au niveau des contrôles
au niveau des réglementations donc les
voitures vont beaucoup plus pollués dans
ces pays n'ont occupé ici en suisse et
puis surtout ce qui se passe c'est que
c'est pas de 30 mille voitures échappe
au recyclage
elles vont finir leur vie dans les pays
qui sont ni organisé et qui n'ont ni les
moyens techniques de recycler donc elles
finiront sur des tombeaux assez ouvert
changé d'appareil pour économiser
l'énergie
est ce une bonne idée ben moi je dis non
bon ça c'est mon expertise a faites vous
votre propre opinion
continuer la réflexion soyez curieux
soyez critique mais josé sur ce qu'on
peut dire de ça aujourd'hui c'est que
cette politique là on continua de cette
politique là c'est faux dit qu'avant
nous amener à un appauvrissement accrue
des ressources et de la biodiversité et
ceci pour toutes les formes de vie que
connaît la planète terre toutes les
formes de vie sont impactés à partir de
là on comprend deux choses 1
la croissance du pib équivaut à des
croissances de la vie sur terre
prochaine fois bien entendu quelqu'un te
réjouir de la croissance du pib
voyez quelqu'un qui à son insu se
réjouit de la décroissance de la vie sur
terre
2 la technologie propre n'existe pas
c'est une illusion collective parce
qu'avant d'être propre ici il n'ya pas
de salir ailleurs le slogan zéro mission
fait partie de cette illusion collective
et là moi je dis attention on nous ment
réfléchissons réfléchissons parce que 0
mission
ce n'est pas possible donc prochaine
fois que vous voyez une publicité qui 0
mission attention on nous ment
réfléchissons réfléchissons prochaine
fois que vous attendez un politicien ou
un média parler d'eux
zéro émission attention prochaine fois
vous voyez publicité zéro émission pas
mal genève shikotan est venu finalement
c'est bien omnubilé par le réchauffement
climatique et les émissions de co2 nous
avons actionné un empoisonnement
généralisée du vivant et ça
personnellement ça m'inquiète
bon c'est sympa cette soirée ensemble
bon bah alors mais alors quelle solution
pour notre futur eh bien il ya une très
belle solution mais une magnifique
solution qui est très simple qui est à
la portée de toutes et de tous c'est
d'acheter moins consommer moins réduire
le nombre d'objets autour de soi ça
c'est une magnifique solution où il a
évolué ht mois sauf si simple que ça
puis en plus vous ferez des économies
d'argent c'est pas mal et quand il
s'agit d'acheter acheté le plus souvent
seconde main acheté seconde main c'est
très précieux parce que le second demain
c'est zéro déforestation zéro énergie
grise zéro pollution chimique 0
ressources naturelles gaspillé zéro
déchets supplémentaires
c'est du win win win win win
hu ont fait mieux que le domaine
bancaire c'est gagnant sur toute la
ligne
achetez seconde main et si vous voulez
encore prolongé tout a échoué encore à
mettre plus de force pour améliorer
situation du vivant et bien prolonger la
vie de vous une plaie pour franchir la
vie de vos objets réparer et usé jusqu
au bout tu as une solution intéressante
pour prendre soin de nos vies voilà le
temps tu mets ta partie est un peu court
pour permettre de faire une présentation
détaillée qui valent en détail ce
n'était pas possible
j'ai accepté ce défi en me disant que
mon but ce soir c'était d'ouvrir des
portes de réflexion d'ouvrir des
réponses réflexion qui je l'espère vous
donneront la curiosité de continuer le
voyage par vous même et avant de vous
quitter
j'aimerais juste vous partager avec vous
une réflexion personnelle qui se résume
en une phrase c'est celle ci je reste
avec vous et si vous obtenez ça j'ai
fait mon job prendre soin de nos objets
c'est prendre soin de nos vies vous
voulez prendre soin de vos vies
prenez soin de vos objets et ce qui est
génial quand on prend soin de la vie ça
fait du bien on vit de petits bonheurs
mais pour vivre petits bonheurs il
s'agit de savoir pourquoi on le fait
donc prochaine fois que vous décidez de
prendre soin d'un objet ajouté cette
dimension dites-vous que au delà de
prendre un objet vous êtes en train de
prendre soin la vie et de votre propre
vie et par là même de ma vie à moi et
pour ça je remercie de tout coeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]